il en faudra plus pour refroidir le
marché immobilier au pays le prix des
maisons ont bondi plus rapidement que
prévu on pensait qu'en début d'année les
prix commencent commencerait se
stabiliser puis au contrat les prix se
sont accélérées au premier trimestre
selon une étude de la firme royal lepage
le prix des propriétés a augmenté de 18
et demi pour cent en un an dans le grand
montréal de 22,3 pour cent sur la rive
sud et même 24 3% sur la rive nord alors
que la hausse atteint 25 % à l'échelle
canadienne vanessa et son conjoint
attendront avant d'acheter découragés
par la surenchère bon c'est pas dans nos
moyens parce que c'est très élevé quand
on voit par exemple il ya des offres ils
font des offres à plus de 80 mille
dollars sur une maison à on se dira
cessé entre notre portée pour le moment
ces extrêmes là ils sont victimes d'un
phénomène de rareté trop peu de
propriété sont à vendre pour le nombre
d'acheteurs habituellement à ce moment
ci de l'année on devrait avoir environ
90 milles propriétés à vendre ou au
québec présentement on est à moins de 40
mètres donc c'est ce qui prime ans qui a
quitté un une immense pression sur les
prix les gens son cas soit fait il ya
des listes de gens qui voudraient
acheter des propriétés cette semaine
mais il ya un manque de vent difficile
aussi de trouver un logement à louer
québec admet même finalement l'existence
d'une crise du logement là on peut le
dire que dans certaines régions
certaines municipalités ya une situation
de crise du logement maintenant ça
changerait parce qu'il faut travailler
sur l'offre c'est ce qu'on fait depuis
le début évidemment on en manque l'offre
de logements au québec il faudrait
effectivement plus de logements et de
maisons à vendre mais les mises en
chantier continue plutôt de chuter alors
que les prix de l'immobilier pourraient
encore augmenter de 15 % au canada le
prix médian d'une propriété dans le
grand montréal est présentement
d'environ 500 71 1000 $ mais si les
prévisions de royal lepage s'avèrent
exacts il frôlerait les six cent mille
dollars d'ici la fin de l'année 2022 ici
sébastien les rosiers radio canada
longueuil